listen i just urge everyone to
watch the movie it is what it is he did
what he did and uh make your own mind up
um it was pretty clear to us sasha baron
cohen is opening up about the scene from
his new movie that might have political
implications
sasha maria thank you for being with us
and everyone is talking specifically
about acing
the movie borat subsequent movie film a
sequel to his 2006
box office hit and cultural phenomenon
nice to meet you
and the scene a moment following an
interview with rudy giuliani
former new york city mayor and personal
attorney to president trump
you're one of my greatest heroes oh
that's so nice thank you yes thank you
sasha and his co-star maria bakalova
stopped by good morning america on
friday where they discussed the much
talked about moment
in the movie maria plays borat's 15 year
old daughter who at one point poses as a
journalist and interviews giuliani
inside a hotel room
i feel like i'm living in a fairy tale
yeah
you're gonna do great okay following the
interview giuliani appears to put his
hand down his pants while lying on a bed
we built a hideaway that i was hiding in
during the entire scene
so i was monitoring it by text but
you know it's my responsibility as a
producer as well to ensure that
the lead actor is
is looked after maria took a moment in
the gma interview to thank sasha for
making her feel safe while filming
i want to thank you that i was sure that
you're going to save me for everything
i've always felt safe
with our team with our crew with sasha
in my corner
i actually never felt that i've been in
danger after word about the scene got
out giuliani quickly fired back on
twitter
in a series of tweets on wednesday he
called it a complete fabrication
and describes his actions in the video
saying quote i was tucking in my
shirt after taking off the recording
equipment as to whether sasha believes
giuliani was inappropriate
the actor encouraged audiences to decide
for themselves
i would say that if the president's
lawyer
found what he did there appropriate
behavior
then heaven knows what he's done with
other female journalists
in hotel rooms and i listen i just
urge everyone to watch the movie
it is what it is he did what he did
and uh make your own mind up help
it was pretty clear to us one person who
made up their mind is patricia arquette
the oscar winner commented on giuliani's
series of tweets
lying down i have never removed a wire
by lying down
never i here to defend america's mayor
rudolph giuliani cohen's personal
feelings about the footage came a day
after his borat persona defended
giuliani on twitter
what was an innocent sexy time encounter
between a consenting man and my 15 year
old daughter
have been turned into something
disgusting by fake news media